it was two weeks ago we had Chris Mannix
on and I wanted to know who Chris
thought might win all of this the bubble
championship and here is Chris Mannix
from Sports Illustrated Blazers Sixers
in fine yep and then we had Chris Haynes
who was on yesterday from TBS Charles
Barkley said yesterday if the Blazers
face the Lakers the Blazers will advance
they're all sampling Chris Mannix who
joins us now from the bubble now were
you serious that the Blazers and Sixers
are gonna play for the championship
let's just say I was so you were you
were sort of serious about that or that
was cool thinking no sort of serious
because I'm convinced that something
crazy is gonna happen in this postseason
I don't believe it's going to be chalk
and if you're looking for like a 1999
Knicks story
it's Portland I mean they've got the two
guards that could win a series by
themselves and I mean they're getting
use of nerd kitchen Zach Collins back so
if you're looking for kind of a
Cinderella tale the only one that fits
that narrative is Portland 76ers though
you like the 76ers and that would be a
surprise as well but why the Sixers I
think the East is more wide open than
then people think I mean I I've said
this to you before I I believe the
three-point shooting is going to be way
down this year in teams that rely
heavily on three-point shooting are not
going to be as effective as they were
before the pandemic and Milwaukee yo
Yanis is not a 3-point shooter but
everybody else is you know with that
group so with with that over-reliance I
think they're a little bit more
vulnerable I look at Philadelphia and I
love the decision Brent Brown made to
move Ben Simmons to power forward
I mean shake Milton is not a household
name but he was playing extremely well
with Simmons out before the pandemic and
he was shooting 50% from three in the 16
games he started this season you move
Simmons the power forward his weakness
as a 3-point shooter are taken away he
can still run the offense that's an
is a terrific post pandemic move by
Brett Browns well I think they're there
in the mix how's the set up in the
bubble
you mean like outside this door cuz I
don't know I mean when's the last time
you were outside that door actually
outside the door Sunday I mean I take it
very seriously how they don't want us to
leave doors so I've been in the
doorframe but I have not stepped outside
the door when can you step outside
I believe it's Sunday night or Monday
morning whenever the seventh test comes
in you've got to have seven consecutive
negative tests I believe that for up
until this point with another one coming
this afternoon so I've just been behind
this door and it's really I said this is
somebody the other day it's it looks
like my college dorm I mean it's like
two unmade beds bottled water on the
floor food packages everywhere
no girls is what it is
you're uh you're fitting right in there
I like it I like him what's your biggest
question mark basketball wise when once
they start playing at the end of the
month I mean it always comes back to the
Lakers because the Lakers I'm very
curious to see just how big an impact
the Bradley Rondo losses are because you
talked to some coaches and they'll say
it's devastating Avery Bradley great
on-ball defender Rondo not having a
great year but runners that one guy in
the backcourt that LeBron just seems to
trust like he just always wants Rondo on
the floor because you know he's got that
play up experience and the ball handling
look playoff Rondo is a real thing there
are other coaches that are like come on
the Lakers are LeBron and Anthony Davis
everybody else is just kind of you know
a supporting character plug a player in
there they're gonna be just fine I'm
very interested to see you know how big
an impact those two losses have
especially in the first round of
playoffs and especially if that
first-round opponent is Portland I mean
I think Rondo beats the six to eight
week time frame to come back he is I
don't think I've ever covered a player
that plays through injury and pain
as often as rajon rondo but if he misses
that first round i think a portland
match-up could be just really compelling
we're talking to Chris Mannix see a
senior NBA writer from Sports
Illustrated be a stitch line policy can
you use that would players or team
officials use it as for competitive
advantage you know most of the ones I've
talked to it just kind of joked about it
and said you know yeah I'm standing up
in my hotel room with binoculars looking
down to see if somebody is stepping
outside the quarantine area there have
been you know reports I mean white
Howard came out and said somebody
reported him for not wearing his mask on
campus but I don't see I don't see it
being employed strategically I don't
think that when the playoffs starts
you're going to have you know Terry
Stotts of the Blazers calling in Anthony
Davis you know report or or something
along those lines I think it's more
about you know just making sure these
players are aware that these rules are
in place we've already seen two guys get
dinged pretty significantly because of
breaking quarantine and the mask wearing
I've been told anyway is the most common
call to that snitch line but soda white
Howard was was he at the pool was that
when he was poolside with the DJ and he
was the only guy there did the DJ snitch
do they have a recording like everything
gets made public like 911 chili come out
I'm wondering if somebody eventually
gets the voice recordings of the snitch
hotline that's a great question and I'll
actually ask it I haven't asked that
question because they they go to great
lengths to make sure you know it's an
anonymous line so I would imagine there
are not recordings but man if there ever
were those ever got out on and that
would be great but it'd be great if
Gregg Popovich was disguising his voice
where he you know he says I mean Doc
Rivers got a joke the body said he's
calling everybody in he's just gonna
keep stitching on on every every guy out
there and see well but more often than
not dead like the quarantine stop the
NBA takes seriously right
like they if you step outside the
boundaries they're gonna come down
pretty hard on you because they've got
to protect you the integrity of the
bubble but the the facemask stuff unless
you do it like 10 times the NBA is not
going to to sit you down like they're
just gonna keep calling you and warning
you and reminding you you have to wear
your mask we were we brought this up
first hour let's take a lot of the
equation who's the face of the NBA I
mean I'd probably say it's Yanis but
Yana certainly doesn't have the charisma
or that face of the NBA feeling I mean
in fact like if you want to look at the
next face of the NBA let's assume let's
say for argument's sake LeBron retired
tomorrow you might be kind of left in
that void that was there when Jordan
retired in late 2000 remember I mean
that was when Kobe was still pretty
young Tim Duncan was kind of the face of
the league but he wasn't face of the
league maybe material Allen Iverson was
there but he didn't really embrace that
role I mean there were three or four
years maybe five years before Kobe
Bryant can ascended into that ROI I
think we might have to wait that long
for someone to do it I mean maybe at
Zion but Zion certainly isn't there yet
so I don't know who that that guy would
be at this point you assume at giannis
because of the MVP the possible MVP he's
gonna win again but he's not a clear-cut
name like it is LeBron when Zion comes
back what is the process that he has to
go through I mean this is it's a good
question because nobody's really being
specific with their answers when I asked
it now there are protocols in place
right for this type of situation if you
have a medical emergency or an excused
absence which the pelicans have
indicated that's what this is you come
back and you undergo a four a day
quarantine but when I ask the NBA what
Zions return protocols are they're not
giving me a direct answer well thing I
keep hearing is that the NBA needs to
learn more about the specific
circumstances about why Zion had to
leave which tells me that you know maybe
they're not fully in the loop about you
know why Zion decided to leave so
it's a minimum of four but it
conceivably could be seven to ten
depending on how the NBA rules on it
what I think is really interesting dance
that I mean early in the season TNT and
ESPN loaded up on pelicans games and
then Zion was out and you're like
billing drew Holiday versus LeBron James
they did it again you know with this
return so like if Zion winds up missing
you know like the first week of the
season
it's Brandon Ingram and the Pelican I
just think it's got it's too bad but
it's even who does a great job with our
stats sent me some numbers that back up
your shake milton comment last seven
games before the NBA shut down just
under 20 points 58% shooting 60% from
three-point range as well so once again
Ethan doing a great job in supplying us
with that stat on What's Wrong McLovin
rissalah I'm the Sheikh Milton guy I'm
like the world's biggest Sheikh Milton
fan now you're going to eat you - Ethan
came to me you could have said hey by
the way Dan Mannix just mentioned shake
Milton I'm a big shake Milton fan here's
some stats
II didn't I only made its gave us is
that why did he think it was exactly
what Ethan did I went along
Ethan is our stance guy remember when
McLovin used to be our stance guy Mannix
yeah well off couldn't pick shake Milton
out of a lineup so let's establish that
um I have you seen the Steph Marbury
documentary I think it's now in flicks
ya know I mean I've seen the clips for
it but it's it's probably on the to-do
list over the last three days in this
but you have nothing to do you're in the
bubble you should be watching some of
these thing you're gonna take a nap
after you do this interview that's not
necessarily true I mean I may take a nap
today but I've done some stuff I've been
relatively busy the Marbury thing is
interesting because at the time member
Felipe Lopez was the big New York City
legend and then Marbury gets drafted by
Milwaukee gets traded to Minnesota for
the rights to Ray Allen in a first round
draft pick and if you look back what
could have been with Marbury and Garnett
and they were good friends and he wanted
to play with Kevin Garnett and it just
never met like I look at Marbury as what
could have been not what was but what
could have been one of the great
pairings that you just never know and
you look away Kevin Garnett's career
went in the Western Conference I mean a
player of that kind of talent only
making it to one Western Conference
Finals I mean that that would not have
been the case if Stephon Marbury was
there as as kind of bonkers as Marbury
went when he was traded to New Jersey
and then Phoenix that you know that
disastrous end in New York I mean he was
a different type of player in Minnesota
like they were on the rise out there I
think there's no doubt they would have
at least made it to the finals during
that that era I don't know if Stef I
feel like I have to see the document I'm
not sure if he ever really regrets it or
says he regrets it but that's one of the
great what-ifs if those two guys never
stayed together would they have been
able to put together the kind of you
know successful pairing that we saw so
many times over but if you look at
trades the Bucks have made so the Bucks
get Ray Allen they traded away Kareem
they traded away dirk nowitzki x' rights
for tractor-trailer like the Bucks have
been involved in some pretty historical
moves down through history here yeah
that tractor-trailer trio a man with I
mean this sort of this sort of
underscores why history prizes anything
to do with it but like even if he honest
even they bow out in like the second
round of these playoffs they're not
trading honest this offseason like it
just yeah unless he tells them flat-out
no I'm not coming back they're they're
not dealing this guy because there's
just simply no way you can get even
close to measurable value in return
they're rolling the dice on Yanis being
a part of this team long you don't think
there could be a situation like Anthony
Davis in New Orleans no I mean I guess
anything's possible I don't foresee that
I mean there were in the years prior to
Anthony Davis making that trade demand
there were plenty of rumblings about
dissatisfaction with what happened there
they made the coaching change David this
was close to money Williams that year
they made the playoffs so there were
build up to that
up until this point you know there's
been nothing but but happiness as far as
I've been told with what Jana steals
mohabbat would have done with that
organization if supply him with an elite
coach that supplied him with the kind of
roster that you you succeed with a
player of that caliber so it would be a
pretty significant 180 in my mind for
Jana to turn around and say you know
what I'm done here it's time to move on
but do you think the Jason Kidd can
actually sell to the potential ownership
of a team hey if you hire me as a coach
I can bring the Greek freak do you think
that that's part of the marketing
strategy of Jason Kidd to become a head
coach again I like Jason Kidd if it is
and if you're an owner I've got you know
something to sell you in Brooklyn like
that's there's not gonna happen he's not
that influential in in Yanis his life
the Gallants would make a
career-defining decision based on you
know going back to play for a coach that
he spent some decent years with good
luck there where we're praying for you I
mean I don't again Dan I don't mind the
solitude it's the food that's a problem
for me that's becoming troubling so beer
and pizza I mean yeah
like I I'm the world's pickiest eater I
don't eat cheese on anything
I don't want Mayo on anything and if
somebody puts either one of those things
on something I won't eat it overall
so like this morning I picked out the
bacon from the meal
I took the fruit cup and I'm done that
might be my only meal of the day like I
just like solitude is fine I mean you
know me I don't really like people
anyway you know like you put like if you
just got me like a pizza delivery I'd be
I'd be cool here for weeks and vice
versa by the way about you not liking
people just I appreciate you let you
know all right good luck thanks dad
thank you that's Chris Mannix he's a
senior NBA writer Sports Illustrated